Speaker 1: I was thrilled to be back yesterday
from my vacation. Many, many people really mad
at me that I was gone for 10 days even though we
had guest hosts. I'm going to tell you a little
bit about that. But in so doing, we're going to
go through some interesting posts from The David
Pakman Show sub Reddit. There are now more than
32000 of our viewers and listeners subscribed
for free to the sub Reddit. You can find it at
David Pakman dot com slash Reddit. Whether you
want to complain about my vacations, talk about
Afghanistan, talk about health care policy,
it's wide open, well moderated,
respectful, mostly respectful discussion.
David Pakman dotcom slash. Read it up. Here's just
an example post. David needs to come back now. I
miss him, which I love to see that I really
was flattered at the number of people that
count on me and wanted me back during my vacation.
It was flattering is really the only way I can
describe it. And also I got a bunch of really
ugly, ugly messages from people. David, how dare
you be on break? I watch your videos every
day and you just leave and you're on vacation,
OK? I mean, I guess, yeah. You know, the show is
free, right? I mean, it's the show. The show is
free. I also got a couple of emails from people
who thought I would or suggested that I cancel
my trip halfway through when the Afghanistan stuff
happened. So even if that made sense, does anybody
know how complicated it is? Like at this point,
you need covid test to get back to the country,
changing flights. Lastminute is outrageously
expensive and accommodations. I mean, that seemed
like an unreasonable expectation. But I'm going to
focus on the positive, not the people threatening
to never watch again because I took a vacation.
The number of people that wrote me messages
saying, David, you know, when you were gone, I
realized I really look forward to listening to the
show and watching the clips each day. I love that.
I'm flattered by that. And I'm glad to be back.
Another post from The David Pakman Show sub
Reddit about independent media. This is a really
interesting post, actually. Do you user noer
of stuff asked, do you think a big issue with
new media is that commentators at some point will
have to choose between pandering to their audience
rather than being objective and telling them what
they need to hear or risk losing viewership? Yes,
we've talked about this this you could describe
that as the phenomenon of audience capture,
where the entity, the show, the host
becomes captured by the audience
and has to do what the audience wants
or expects rather than what they
believe or believe is best. I have made a
commitment and I've talked about this before.
We sometimes disagree. By we I mean my audience
with me or parts of my audience with me.
We sometimes disagree about things. There's
disagreement right now with some in my audience
about Afghanistan. There's been disagreement in
the past about all sorts of different issues.
Sometimes, you know, there's like a vaccine
skeptical component of the audience. There's
people in the audience who didn't like my view
of the Israeli-Palestinian conflict or whatever.
But the promise I've made is I want to be the
anti grifter in the sense that I'm just going
to tell you what I believe and I'm not going to
tell you what I think the audience wants to hear,
because I don't want to lose a portion of the
you know, if there's any criticism of what I say
on the show, it should be substantive because
you disagree with me or think that I'm wrong,
but not because anybody thinks that I'm coming up
with a take that will be the best for the audience
so that we don't lose viewership. That's never
been what I've done. So that's been my commitment.
I think I've stuck to it. Last post I want to
highlight, yes, I did have sort of one of these
accidental Portman toes yesterday. I used the
word question eight and I meant questioning and
vaccinate I some kind of question, ading. I put
it together and user who's up who's saying people
should not be questioning the wisdom of getting
inoculated against covid. And I can absolutely
agree with that. If people want to put that on
Urban Dictionary, by all means, go ahead. But
there is no we should not question it. Question
it would be questioning. Vaccination, let's do it,
let's get ourselves vaccinated. All right, join
the discussion at David Pakman Dotcom Redit.